Hi I’m John Green, welcome to Crash Course
Navigating Digital Information.
So, the internet is a place where you can
meet friends for life from halfway around
the world, you can keep in touch with your
loved ones, you can learn new languages and
pick up new skills.
It’s also a place where your mother can
tag you in an extremely detailed Facebook
post about the night of your birth that all
your friends can see.
And it’s a place where you can accidentally
like your ex’s new boyfriend’s Instagram
selfie from three years ago.
God it would be hard to be a young person
on the Internet right now.
I really admire your fortitude and resilience.
These days, a lot of us are asking whether
the Internet is a net positive or a net negative
in our lives.
But I tend to think that question might be
what the Buddhist Zen masters called, A question
wrongly put.
Instead, the better question might be, “How
can I make the Internet a more positive force
in my life, and the lives of others?”
And part of the answer, I think, is that better
information leads to better decision making,
which leads to a better world.
So for the sake of our collective souls, let’s
improve our information sorting.
INTRO
As you may remember from our first episode,
we’ve teamed up with MediaWise, with support
from Google to bring you this series.
Our friends at the Stanford History Education
Group -- or SHEG -- have done a lot of research
on how internet users evaluate the information
they find.
They’ve tested middle school, high school,
and college students, history professors,
and fact checkers, who were by far the best
at judging the reliability of information.
Professional fact checkers work with news
organizations to verify facts.
Sometimes that means they look over articles
before they’re published to ensure their
content is accurate and up to date.
They might call up a source, for example,
to double check the spelling of their name.
Once, there was a profile of me in the New
Yorker, and the fact-checker asked me questions
for OVER AN HOUR.
And in the end, the piece contained no errors.
Although, it did an illustration I found a
tad unflattering.
To be fair, the illustration also contained
no errors.
I just don’t think I like my face.
Anyway, fact checkers also work for publications
whose sole purpose is to verify claims made
by public figures or on the internet, and
explain why they are or are not true.
Snopes and Politifact are some of the more
well-known fact-checking sites.
So, in the Stanford study, college students,
history professors, and fact-checkers were
all asked to look at two websites.
One website belonged to the American Academy
of Pediatrics[1], or the AAP, the main professional
organization of pediatricians.
The other site belonged to the American /College/
of Pediatricians, or the ACP.
Now of course, they sound very similar, but
the ACP is actually an organization that broke
away from the AAP because the AAP supports
adoption by LGBTQ couples.
The AAP is a large, well-respected professional
organization.
My kids’ pediatrician is a member.
The ACP, on the other hand, is a much smaller,
more ideologically-motivated interest group.
But looking at the two sites, many of the
professors and students thought ACP’s site
was more credible.
Why?
Because they focused on the site itself.
They spent time examining and reading the
website, noticing that there were footnotes,
and checking out its design elements.
One student said of ACP’s website, “I
can automatically see this source and trust
it just because of how official it looks...even
the font and the way the logo looks makes
me think this is a mind hive that compiled
this.”[2]
The ACP’s website may have looked official,
but when compared the the AAP’s website,
its information was less reliable.
AAP is the trustworthy group.
So, the professors and students focused on
the websites themselves and how they /presented/
information to decide which was more credible.
That meant they didn’t do a great job evaluating
the source itself.
The fact-checkers on the other hand, did much
better.
That’s because they consistently asked themselves
three questions while evaluating the sites:
1.
Who is behind this information?
2.
What is the evidence for their claims?
And 3.
What do other sources say about the organization
and its claims?
These questions are a really useful framework
when you want to interpret the accuracy of
information you’ve encountered.
Let’s begin with who’s behind the information:
First, we want to know who exactly is sharing
it with you.
A friend on facebook?
A stranger?
A news organization?
Is it promoted post that a company paid to
insert into your feed?
An anonymous social media account?
And then we should ask ourselves WHY they
are sharing it.
Each of those sharers mentioned could have
very different reasons for presenting information
in a particular way.
I am, for instance, incentivized by my career
to say that I think teenagers should read
contemporary fiction, specifically contemporary
fiction written by me, and I am more likely
to share stories of people who benefited from
reading contemporary fiction.
And even your personal friends have motivations
for sharing what they do online--they may
want to signal what kind of person they are
(or wish to be seen as), or they may want
to win over others to their worldview, or
they may be trying to get someone’s attention
with a subtweet.
A journalist might be sharing information
because they think it’s important for their
readers to know, but, of course, that decision
is based on their own personal experiences.
An advocate for a particular cause might be
sharing information to persuade others to
join that cause.
Once you’ve established who is sharing information
with you and thought about why they might
be doing so, you get to the heart of the matter.
The claim itself.
Take a moment to identify what, if any, claims
are actually being made.
It could be a factual claim or an opinion
statement.
Reading is a useful skill is a factual claim.
Reading The Fault in Our Stars will make your
life better, clear your skin, and improve
your wardrobe is an opinion statement.
And a true one.
Next you’ll search for two things: whether
they’ve backed up that claim with evidence
and whether that evidence is from a reliable
source.
Evidence could come in the form of a link
to the article or study they’re referencing.
It could be a video or photo illustrating
what they’ve described.
It could even be the name of someone who made
the claim in the first place.
The next step is to look at the source of
this evidence.
Is it a reputable source, like a trusted news
organization or an expert in the field?
Or is it from some random blog you’ve never
heard of?
Does it back up its claims with other sources
or explain how its information was gathered?
If you’ve never heard of the source of this
information, you can use a search engine to
discover what others say about it.
The sheer /existence/ of evidence is not enough
to verify a claim.
The /absence/ of evidence, on the other hand,
is reason to be skeptical of its veracity
until you can verify it.
And that brings us to the final and really
vital step: what do others say about this
claim?
Whenever you’re checking on the truth, you
can and should check multiple sources to see
what other information is out there.
Check a search engine or a website known to
be an authority on the topic to see what others
have published about it.
If a trustworthy source backs it up, great.
If you can’t find evidence for that claim
or you find evidence to the contrary, then
you can be fairly certain it’s not true.
So these three questions -- who’s behind
it, what’s the evidence, and what do others
say -- really kind of put information through
the ringer.
Let’s try it out in the Thought Bubble.
Here’s a tweet from Steve S. @steelseller002:
Each American uses 25 plastic straws daily.
We should use metal ones!!!
All right.
Let’s begin by asking who’s behind this
information and what motivated them to post
it.
His profile says his name is Steve S. His
handle is @steelseller002.
So you search “Steve S., steel seller.”
It turns out, @steelseller002 /sells steel/.
Perhaps he loves the environment and wants
to help reduce waste.
He also might just want to sell more steel.
So now, you look at the evidence of this information.
He didn’t give us any.
Even if he had provided a source, that wouldn’t
guarantee this is trustworthy -- claims should
be backed up by evidence, and not all evidence
is created equal.
But the absence of it is suspicious.
Finally, you want to look into what /other/
sources have to say about this claim.
As we’ve established, some are more credible
than others, but all sources have their limits.
So it’s important to seek multiple trustworthy
sources when fact-checking.
You do a simple internet search: “Number
of straws used by Americans per day.”
The New York Times cites two research firms
that say America as a whole uses between 170
and 390 million straws per day.[3] That’s
a little over one per person per day at most.
But search results from Time Magazine,
the Washington Post,
and The Seattle Times cite another statistic:
500 million per day.
Some publications, though, say that statistic
was compiled by a 9-year-old who polled straw
manufacturers.
Regardless, that estimate is still fewer than
two straws per American per day.
So we have no consensus.
But from our research it seems somewhere between
170 and 500 million straws per day is more
accurate.
Far fewer than Steve’s claim.
Steve.
Thank you, Thought Bubble.
I just...we were just talking about the name
Steve, and whether anybody is named Steve,
and I asked Zulaiha if she knew anybody named
Steve, and she said, “I don’t anyone young
named Steve.
Just one guy in his late 20s.”
Oh God.
Oh God, Father Time is coming for me.
What were we talking about, Stan?
Right, checking with multiple sources made
us pretty skeptical of Steve’s claim.
Typical for an old guy in his late 20s.
Now, that doesn’t mean plastic straws should
be widely distributed, or that they don’t
have negative impacts,or that you can trust
@plasticseller002 on Twitter--but regardless
of how you feel about straws, we need to have
these discussions with real data and real
cost-benefit analyses.
Better information makes for better decisions.
You’re going to hear me say that a few times.
Now I know that this seems like an absurd
amount of work to check the veracity of one
tweet out GAJILLIONZ of tweets.
But there is no simple, magical way to have
an information feed that is always reliable.
And so when you encounter information that
comes from sources you don’t already trust,
you have to be suspicious of it.
And even when it comes from sources you do
already trust, you have to be a little suspicious
of it.
Interrogating the information we come across
online is just so important.
You cannot believe everything you read -- but
that doesn’t mean you should distrust everything
you read, either.
This is actually its own problem.
We’ve become so skeptical of widely believed
information, that we’ll believe any evidence
that counters that information, regardless
of whether it is accurate.
There’s a very fine line between being skeptical
-- or, not easily convinced -- and being cynical,
or generally distrustful of everyone else’s
motives.
A healthy dose of skepticism improves our
critical thinking and judgement.
But cynicism clouds our judgement with negativity
and suspicion.
It’s really difficult for any of us, on
a minute-by-minute basis, to carefully vet
the contents of every tweet or reddit post
we see while scrolling and swiping.
But if we can carefully interrogate some sources,
we can find some that we regularly trust,
which makes it easier to navigate the Internet
over time.
Whenever your inner skeptic speaks up, your
fact-checking can begin by checking in with
your trusted sources.
But of course, the problem with this is that
your inner skeptic may speak up mostly when
you see information that seems like it must
be wrong to you because it does not align
with your pre-existing worldview.
Here’s an example from my own life: I don’t
want to alienate anyone here, so I’ll use
like, hypothetical examples.
Let’s say there’s some horrible football
club named United Manchester FC.
Watching one of their games recently, I shared
a tweet about how United Manchester FC are
awarded more penalty kicks than any other
team, and how it is blatantly unfair.
And everyone agreed with me, because almost
everyone in my feed also reviles United Manchester
FC.
It was only much later that I learned that
the football team I support has actually been
awarded more penalties over the past 25 years
than United Manchester.
The disinformation did not trip up my inner
skeptic, because it seemed like the kind of
thing that would be true.
So we shouldn’t /just/ wait for our inner
skeptic to tap us on the shoulder about information
we disagree with.
We need to make a habit of quickly checking
out whatever we find interesting or shareable
or that makes us emotional.
Because that is the kind of stuff that changes
our decisions, and also changes us.
And so we have to train those internal falsehood
alarms to respond not just to potential misinformation
we disagree with.
That’s why fact-checkers are so good at
this -- they have to check everything.
But this work is like any other kind of training:
the more you utilize your information analyzing
muscles, the stronger they’ll get.
So, we’ll continue to work out next time,
but, you know, not, like, with movement.
Just...up here.
I’ll see you then.
For this series, Crash Course has teamed up
with MediaWise, a project out of the Poynter
Institute that was created with support from
Google.
The Poynter Institute is a non-profit journalism
school.
The goal of MediaWise is to teach students
how to assess the accuracy of information
they encounter online.
The MediaWise curriculum was developed by
the Stanford History Education Group based
on civic online reasoning research that they
began in 2015.
If you’re interested in learning more about
MediaWise and fact-checking, you can visit
@mediawisetips on Instagram.
________________
[1] https://sheg.stanford.edu/civic-online-reasoning/website-reliability
[2] https://papers.ssrn.com/sol3/papers.cfm?abstract_id=3048994
[3]https://medium.com/@MediaWiseTips/do-americans-really-use-500-million-straws-a-day-%E3%83%84-7e711416b10c